über corona zu sprechen ist das eine
aber dann das virus tatsächlich zu haben
infiziert zu sein ist was ganz anderes
ab dem moment spielen viele diese angst
vor diesem tückischen virus und das hat
eine weitere prominente in diesen
stunden auf ganz besonders bewegende art
und weise geschildert hallo leute ich
wollte mich einfach kurz melden deutlich
seit drei vier tagen angeschlagen und
ist auch nicht besser geworden
und obwohl ich extrem aufgepasst habe
und ohne maske die wohnung gar nicht
verlassen habe und handschuhe hatte und
alles zu hause noch mal desinfiziert
habe habe ich leider jetzt auch corona
und das schlimme ist ja ich weiß nicht
ob ich übermorgen lebe und das machen
wir wieder in ordnung
ja und bei uns im studio nochmal bild
unterhaltungschefin janina kirsch ganz
viele menschen hat das heute bewegt bei
uns auf der seite warum so sehr ich
denke weil sie eine der ersten ist die
wirklich offen mit ihrer angst auch so
umgegangen ist also es haben schon
einige prominente darüber gesprochen
dass die kommune hatten aber auch
teilweise wirklich erst im nachhinein
einige von denen wir wussten haben es
aber auch verschwiegen oder wollten auch
gar nicht erzählen dass die korona haben
und ich glaube das ist es diese diese
dieser offene umgang mit der angst davor
was jetzt passiert natürlich fragt man
sich jetzt warum ist sie ausgerechnet so
panisch also was versetzte jetzt in so
eine wahnsinnige angst aber ich bin zum
glück bis jetzt nicht betroffen gewesen
und ich weiß auch nicht wie ich mich
fühlen würde ob ich nicht auf einmal
auch weil der panik empfinden würde wenn
ich auf einmal fahre ich habe corona und
ich glaube dass realisiert man erst dann
wenn man es dann tatsächlich wirklich
hat weißt du wie sehr geht wir wollten
einige sprechen heute abend mit ihr
wir wollten eigentlich heute mit ihr
sprechen sie hat das gespräch jetzt aber
abgesagt weil sie einfach wahnsinnig
erschöpft ist und sie hat ja auch zu uns
gesagt haben sie auch angerufen dass
beziehungsweise mit ihr gesprochen dass
ihre lunge brennt und dass sie sehr
trockenen husten hat also sie ist halt
wirklich krank das ist nicht einfach es
gibt ja auch viele menschen die haben
krone merkens nicht sie ist wirklich
krank und sie hat das gespräch jetzt
abgesagt weil sie einfach sehr erschöpft
ist und deswegen ja und was auch noch
ein interessanter aspekt es ist dass sie
sagt sie hat sich an alles gehalten sie
hat ständig desinfiziert jetzt immer
eine maske getragen und sie weiß nicht
woher es kommt und das ist ja
unglaublich das größte problem momentan
liegt das man halt einfach die herde
nicht mehr zurückverfolgen
ja auf jeden fall werden wir dauer
weiter dran bleiben wie es ihr geht
vielleicht schaffen ist ja dann doch
noch mal die tage wenn es etwas besser
wird noch mal mit ihm zu sprechen wie
wir uns dazu dann können wir sagen liebe
kader auf jeden fall alles gute
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren